2 p.m. today I'm excited to see what
happens you guys know the words to this
song Let's see if you
do Hans Kim
everybody hey all
right it's good to be here I'd like to
thank Matt re for getting cancelled on
the first joke of his
special so I don't have to watch the
rest of that
[__] guess I'll never find out what that
guy does for a
living I uh like Matt R I am the Matt R
of ugly people um I actually have a lot
of sex it's pretty cool I used to date a
beauty pageant winner from El
Salvador yeah she had Miss 13 tattooed
on her
forehead
thank
you what's up
man I hate poor people uh they're always
trying to make me feel bad for growing
up
rich sorry my parents had their [__]
together they didn't have a panic
baby I can't take care of myself maybe
this baby
can all right thank
you all right Hans Kim
shooting his shot against Matt R this
week for some reason what do you have
against Matt re I have a lot of minutes
to write and everyone is fair game I
love Matt R I think he's great I just uh
I don't I don't watch a lot of specials
but I watched stavros's special he got
me tickets it's one of the best specials
I've ever seen go check it out hell yeah
I was about to call him a coward for
backtracking on the Matt rif thing but
now I love the guy
[__] M no I uh that was a good recovery
that was a good honest answer to your
question I like that what are you gonna
say when Matt re is a guest on the show
in a couple weeks oh hey
Matt what's going on in life Hans Kim um
I just got back from Vancouver BC had a
little layover in CAC which is where
that's what you were doing in Seattle
okay you got me you earlier I look at
hans's location all the time I keep an
eye on him it's true I keep him from
doing shitty open mics right he's
addicted to shitty open mics I have and
when you're addicted to shitty here's a
little insight in the comedian world is
like when you do that it [__] up your
timing it makes you not like if you're
doing a shitty room filled with idiots
and there's like 12 morons there and
you're trying a new joke that might be
[__] amazing but you're doing it in
front of 12 idiots and they don't laugh
or they go
then you don't like the joke that could
have been great so by doing shitty shows
it's not a good barometer for how things
work so I always keep an eye on Han so
I'll yell at him sometimes I'll be like
what the [__] are you doing at that
[__] club right now like it's
literally like a uh Tony do you do this
with women also like that you date and
stuff do you make them F no I don't have
it's only men that Tony tracks on his
phone exactly I have the we're on the
board one time calling Tony Gay it is
true that's one that is one one down and
to huge Applause by the way literally
never gets
old I uh I love it whatever whatever the
people want that's what you get who
knows there could be dildos at the arena
flying around uh we're just a few weeks
away anything can happen speaking of the
Arena I mean the whole world is talk the
whole Kil Tony Universe at least is
talking about this upcoming battle it's
the first thing like this we've ever
done and uh your uh regular ship is on
the line how's things going with that
how do you feel leading it's going great
you know I uh I love negativity and
hatred in my life uh and somehow you're
the good guy in this deep Madness your
guitar is literally I mean you have to
go like side it's more this way I don't
know if you feel that but it's got to be
like that way a little bit sardine stage
okay it ain't my fault I know I know but
but the I got put
[Laughter]
here anyone by
me all right that's right I'm gay and
I'm an [__] everybody I love it
welcome to my show everyone welcome to
the gay [__] show everybody here I
am the old gay [__] put a dick in me
cuz I'm a gay [__] you know what I'm
saying all right Hans what else is going
on in your world let's talk about it um
I uh I I recently installed a bag of
water above my bed and I'm sucking on
that that's pretty cool uh what the [__]
are you talking about this man lives
like a
hamster you put wood pellets in your
[__] bathroom too you just [__]
directly on the floor Hans is that
Korean
efficiency he has little tunnels in his
whole place that he just crawls through
you are what you
eat you eat hamsters I mean yeah give it
a sh I love
it so uh let's get into this more what
the [__] do you mean a bag of water over
your bed I got the biggest camel bag I
could find found the stud put a nail
hung it up and now I'm just sucking on
water all day so you filled the camel
back up with water you nailed it to your
wall is this something you saw a on the
Internet or somebody else do this is
your own idea this is 100% original Hans
Kim
idea this is absolutely incredible I
love this you gave me money and now I'm
just using it that's right I love that
that's one of my favorite things is to
make sure that the people that I make
sure get rich spend that [__] money
there's nothing worse than someone that
holds on to it a lot there's a lot of
Thrifty people that uh you know and you
were once one of them I yeah I still am
uh but no yeah you're helping me a lot
you really shame me uh about uh being
cheap being cheap he wears a lot of free
t-shirts that people give them like
you'll see it like you can just tell
like it's like what's that one that's a
real this one is a Leman Brothers It's a
you bought that yeah on Amazon it's a
it's kind of a protest yeah I don't get
it yeah what is the they were
responsible for the 2008 financial
crisis uh oh and you bought that that
yeah with the money
yeah recently you bought this recently
yeah about 2 weeks ago nice man hell
yeah my man's trying to get some
communist [__] yeah respect I also am
trying to do that so how are things with
the girlfriend she's great you know
she's very American I'm Asian you know
she you know ignores some of the nice
things I do for her uh she's like oh
you're here oh can you get me some water
uh and you're like here here's my
[Laughter]
take it out of your mouth yeah I put a I
put a water bag above her bed are you
[__] serious yeah I'm starting sleep
in different beds well yeah I mean she
has her own house I live in my house uh
it causes a lot of stress because you
know she likes to spend a lot of time
with me she does yeah that's an ongoing
theme yeah it's it's crazy it's like I'm
a podcaster by nature and she's just
taking away all my podcasting time but
uh no she's she's uh
a podcaster by Nature so let's talk more
about this water bag do you drink it all
in like one night do you refill it you
let the water sit there for a few days
how long does it take you to get through
this bag of water it's like 5 days of
water just hanging above my head gross
wow that is incredible it's like a why
what the [__] you don't want fresh water
[__] well if you have a cup you
have to like turn over and like make
sure you sit up and drink it if you have
a thing you just like lay there and just
suck on it oh my God but that's cold
it's room temperature water but gross
it's just like you're just like when
you're laying in bed the thing that gets
you out of bed is like dry mouth so now
I solve that the thing that gets you out
of bed is dry mouth do you have a tube
you piss into as well yeah is is this a
perfect cycle you yeah dude that's the
next thing you need [__] filtration
to piss into and then you just drink the
water then it's Infinity days not 5 days
you're just your own Human Centipede at
that point you don't ever need to do
anything and then if you add a podcast
mic into the mix you can literally just
do everything from there a zoom screen
across from you have everybody zoom in
your annoying girlfriend can stay in the
room with you and feel like you're with
her right she can keep an eye on you
right you you're I I thank you for the
this advice I know you're joking but I
might actually do it I want updates on
it I'm excited to find out how it goes
there he goes ladies and gentlemen Hans
Kim with a brand new minute a brand new
interview we found out a lot
[__] got a bag of water on the
wall you can't make this [__] up I swear
I don't talk to these people throughout
the week like hey what are we going to
talk about in the interview I find out
with you like you can't even write that
[__] he's got a bag of water like no
sitcom would do that cuz they'd be like
oh that's unbelievable who's going to
believe that he's sucking out of a bag
of water one more